[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
or we talk about whatever we want no we
got two here surprised you guys keep
having me here I am surprised every time
TIFF it hits me else I go you want to
come like real they love you you know
that I read the comments we don't what
they do
yeah he's my favorite people really be
recognizing me like oh my god I say yo
JK news I even in Oakland I was like
Oakland or international I know I see
you at the airport know like at one of
the towers Oakland Raiders games and say
that Oakland International Airport
[Laughter]
little areas well yeah but I'm glad to
be back
hey your dad your dad your father yes I
am above do you ever say as a father and
you say something annoying as a father
yes and I think that's it like a rites
of passage we may come and dad something
in your mouth you should we wait for you
to chew that okay my you know yeah I
think is this a rite of passage as a dad
did you get to say you know what as your
father I won't stand for it but what
about you're talking to a third party no
ik as a father and then you use that as
like a wedge to [ __ ] get you boost
your image up even more or like to boost
your issue up like you're pumping up a
tire yes yes I mean I've done it before
once or twice I'm not proud of it but
I'm also not ashamed of it I get it cuz
I as a father I feel like I am the stoat
that right you know to brag a little bit
okay now my follow-up question when you
had kids did it drive you and your wife
a little bit apart any distance at all
well in concerned when I met my wife in
high school I'm in college she was
already two months pregnant so it wasn't
a wedge to really drive apart because it
was already established but one of the
great things about her is that she
supports mine rulings even if she
doesn't agree with it in that moment and
we will talk about it later but in front
of our daughter we are you know united
front
yeah I had that happen a couple
where I punish me that my wife
necessarily did not agree with are there
my wife yeah didn't necessarily agree
with but in front of her afterwards well
sure wife to after huh like you know so
I punish the kid first and then since
you don't agree with me your ass is
getting grounded too much well she has
to sleep with the kid oh no it's not
yeah in the twin thanks to my son you
know but in in that moment we were
united front and my daughter knows that
like she can't do the whole dad do you
mind if I go and her mom has already
told her no she knows I'm all I'm only
got my eggs my plan has anything else
what did your mother say yeah that's no
first thing on my eggs and then she
liked what she told me come on you then
I can give whatever judgment I want but
I will never be like yeah no no forget
what your mom said you can go ahead and
do it no I'm not gonna do comes to me
and I I see he has a black guy I
immediately punch his other eye I got it
I got her back first yes so and then I
go okay so what did you want to ask and
then he asked me if I gave him the
background like no you fell yes he's a
funny two story he'll I fell on a
doorknob little laughs whooping is that
my daughter got she got us some shorts
considered she was still in elementary
school and so she got this little bit
and my daughter had whips because it was
it was a small belt but she had welts on
the lace because he had on shorts so she
went to school the next day and wore
shorts and half the school teachers saw
the whips on her legs and call it the
cops no so and I picked up from at the
school we get home the cops are waiting
there and they're aggressive with me
like I did it and I'm just like I didn't
even throw her under the bus I was like
hey man listen you know she was talking
[ __ ] to a real and this is what the [ __ ]
happens right so the guy was like what
one of the cops is two costumes I walk
my partner needs to go in and talk to
your daughter alone you know just to
find out what's going on other cops
talked to me he was like hey man I get
it you know I just put my kids to you
guys you just have to be careful where
you work them so you'd leave no more
except type of stuff but I didn't even
throw under the bus like first of all oh
lady did that [ __ ] okay
and I'm only
I'm telling you that is because you're
here with gun and I don't want problems
by myself my wife has a really big hands
he changed his tires with no tools yeah
she's really big hands like I've said
she could handle a car yeah no doubt I'm
saying you see like choose bullets like
sunflower seeds this guy's like it's
like but yeah we even in left even in
that moment we were still a united front
I was gonna throw her numbers like well
my wife XD I wouldn't even s tell ya I'm
gonna take the chart for then she better
build me up I'm stitching on everything
like all that [ __ ] she did on fraudulent
taxes I'm telling the whole issue nice
well at least you haven't told anybody
about it yet yeah that's smart you know
I worry about that [ __ ] man cuz it's
like you know I'm an Enzo nuff having
kids and [ __ ] and I'm like dude but I
know people who have had kids and then
like I had a lawyer who was obsessed
with his wife and then he had a kid and
then he really didn't give a [ __ ] about
his life anymore he's like all about his
kid now Wow
interests and he was on the same page
with the wife like crazy before the kid
he was I mean then I can see right
you're never inside the room for their
relationship you just sort of see what
you see and so my understanding though
is that they had a pretty tight
relationship and then like after the kid
it was just kinda like what's the race
if you don't mind me asking a race of
the the white your friends they were
Dominican okay no you know was going
because I live in our Glendale and
Glendale is yeah it's a lot of Armenians
and yeah and honestly like I feel like
the hierarchy in it Armenian family is
the father the kid the grandparents then
the mom Wow
yeah like the grand brothers hold a lot
of weight and the kids like really
become like I like picked up my daughter
from school and I've seen the mom get
out of the front seat in the passenger
seat and then getting the back seats to
the Cape begin the first Oh No so I've
seen I've seen that that shift before so
I think that's I think it's more of a
cultural thing that you when you see
that type of thing I don't think you
have anything cuz like you're white so
you know a white man you'll always be in
control okay
it's not like there's not like a
hierarchy yeah it's just white man yeah
period that's it it's a hard period
right after that everybody kind of just
gets in where we could say that's true I
had a white delivery guy do that I don't
for my pizza's your oyster what do you
so how are you guys figure it out when
there's like two two white guys yeah two
or more how do they figure it I'm we
have a man whoever has the most money oh
that's the money fans we have a white
off where we try to see who can
pronunciate there's a lot of pros going
back and forth yeah well that's the
difference I mean look at the shoes or
is there what is the what is the marker
of the tribe it's just like hey do you
have Armani on and say oh cool well I
have I have Victor [ __ ] sigur rós
victory and veronik yeah where's the
corn the war guys come on there's eggs
bodies friends yeah he's at the bottom
of the totem pole hmm yeah so you were
blonde Thiago you're [ __ ] winning the
argument play return all right well I
mean it goes without saying cuz I can it
spell it me I can't I didn't know how to
pronounce if you want your gun to my
head in black spell Balenciaga I'm in
this [ __ ] right now
I'm like hey Siri call my family tell
him I love him my god was just I know
what it is I can't get my hand there
like you'll pronounce door Tommy oh [ __ ]
like hey Siri call my fake all my wife
and tell her that I'm not coming home
yeah because I don't even know how to
say it where did you say George or do
you like Kristen D or like the one that
through the person yeah listen to your
geologist dir yard yeah the or you don't
work don't you think Palisades 106
yesterday I met this girl who could not
pronounce the Palisades in shows she was
avoiding it what what's the saying we're
gonna go to the park why you view
Palisades she's like I don't know I
can't saying I want to say like palácio
da see you want to say Palacio de her
brains like firing off we have some
words that just give me an amazing
amount of trouble that shouldn't like
the opposite of an urban area is a rule
that one's hard rule yeah hi I don't
mess it up it's just you can't tell the
difference between me saying rule my
don't break this rule and rule yeah two
hours right
are you I said are you country
oh wait go ahead for the smell in this
jelly roll right is it are you huh and
are you huh no no are you are Al yes
are you are a blue roll
why did you spell it correctly I felt
bad for him I pitied him it's as if I
sent a homeless person right thing to
say you know what though I can't spit oh
my god just turn down your white just a
little bit wait what cuz you're that I
had to I'd pity me so much man yeah he's
my spelling bee he's not helping you
right can't spell like when I invoke
alized the words or the letters I can't
do it when I type it out or write it out
wow that's great I can't do it I'm just
not a song how do you spell this I'm
like yeah a spelling bee I always had a
hard time I don't know have to like say
it like visualize the letters and then
see them yeah but when I type it out I'm
just like that and then there's no red
squiggly line and I just right click and
it [ __ ] change I tell you what this
English is done it's a lot of words that
are just like like knife oh why is [ __ ]
that word there's a [ __ ] cave
yeah but the K for it what about all of
these silent peas that [ __ ] tear exact
oh we both went off on pterodactyl
ammonia yeah the more you give me
national you guys know what I do when I
chill and watch spelling bees I like to
order food from post mates
really
talk to you by my post mates yeah so
postmates is your personal food delivery
grocery delivery and whatever kind of
delivery service all year round yeah
that's right baby
so check this out when you need red wine
at 4:00 p.m. yes you need some batteries
at 10:00 p.m. I do you need a burrito at
a.m. whenever you need it post made it
yep anything you're craving post mates
can deliver they're the largest
on-demand network in the US and offer
delivery from all the restaurants
grocery and convenience stores and
traditional retailers you could possibly
want or need yeah 24 hours a day 365
days a year
post mates will bring you what you need
within the hour
so you don't even need anymore trip to
the store you don't even have to know
where the store is
post mates will deliver anything to you
so download the app for iOS or Android
for free browse local restaurants and
businesses and track your delivery and
real-time payment for a limited time
post mates is giving our listeners
that's you guys
$100 do this myself a free delivery
credit for the first 7 days to start
your free deliveries download the app
and then use the code off the record and
that's the code off the record Oh F F th
e re Co Rd for $100 of free delivery
credit that's right baby
so it's for your first 7 days when you
download the post meats app anything you
need anytime you need it post made it
download post mates and save with the
code off the record we're gonna leave a
little download link in the description
box below and you'll see our code right
there too
just in case you don't know how to spell
it because you know guys like me need a
Spelling Bee champion to help me out but
you can get it at off the record or type
in code off the record
post made it baby thank you what's cool
spelling bee vids Joe Jimmy's ha yeah
give me some 6 spelling bee
Indians vs. Chinese kids going at it at
in deeds always win I know
use it in a sentence I'm like what the
[ __ ] is it laughing no it's dramatic or
like okay that's thank you okay I know I
get it though with because with my very
shitty knowledge I can sometimes figure
out what a word is just because of Latin
root words which helps a lot it does
help a lot I know yeah cuz like I know
Spanish so then sometimes like when
there's a word I can I can determine
what it actually means because it's the
left you can suss it or if you even go
to like Italy or something - right like
you use a Spanish to help you decipher
some Italian words oh yeah it was weird
we're in Italy I was like I can
understand like 75% of what these people
are saying you know why you know what I
don't know I'm guessing you know why cuz
a rape
what oh yeah historical read a lot of
[ __ ] historical read yeah oh I
thought you meant like another reason
why no no cuz a cultural you know tell
me more about rape
I mean I can go off on that for quite a
while I mean rapes bred languages
languages culture all estrogen all like
like Vikings and yeah yeah that's crazy
man you're the history buff I am tell us
there's a lot of rape going on in
history it's pretty sad dude until like
even 150 years ago it's all goddamn
prevalent that it's not we're so lucky
to live right now you have no idea my
friend has a theory of why British girls
are ugly but Scandinavian girls are
really [ __ ] high what's the theory so
his theory is that the Vikings came to
Britain and took all the hot girls and
to come to the Scandinavian countries
sometimes is the easiest thing you come
on you you no no no wait no wait I like
her and neither come on man she's like a
seven so then they all took all the hot
hottest girls and then brought them over
but sometimes when hot people like
procreate they don't make very
good-looking kid that's Wow baby was
born
although
oh god baby to me that question is being
answered in real time because [ __ ]
Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie had a kid
and I think she's like what nine now so
we gotta wait we are way quite a while
to see oh my god Kim Kardashian Kanye's
kids are freaking beautiful what about
the reverse ugly duckling when the
babies are [ __ ] hot and then they
grow up and you're like no the reverse
ugly duckling how do you would say that
like to it oh my god you change the
lastest you a pop you know the kid from
[ __ ] sixth sense I can no II got big
he's just he's like I want to eat
everything Macaulay Culkin's like that
too but call it call it a dick crack
drugs ever seen let me pull up a vision
but she lit up she looks cute Rohan Oh
again drugs were there they gotta give
it a pass you know usually it's not
genetics it's drugs yeah yeah drugs are
all the Sixth Sense kid I don't know if
he that's Mathilda yeah I know I can't
see her except for anything about this
like dessert yes that's a sharp nose and
nose like a Harold I just like a
terrifying
I think she looks like Matilda am I
crazy is she like you kid I wouldn't
call her hot but she's average yeah I
don't think she was supposed to be hot
yeah Matilda was don't get me wrong
the tools are dying right she's at nine
but she didn't go from like one side of
the spectrum I feel about there she
looks like a healthier
what's the young like that plays Jessica
Jones yeah yeah yeah looks like her sure
what the [ __ ] is her name I'm a fan I'm
a [ __ ] fan yes I'm fan something I am
yeah that's why you're not in the club
yeah you can answer the big question
what's a real name
[ __ ]
I cited her the other day too in
something damn I really yeah do you cite
people a lot sure if I need to it looks
like it yeah yeah well I pull them over
first it's a smart joke if you guys
missed that one you said I got nothing
yeah we've got replay replay to figure
it out
geo didn't get it I got it I just didn't
think it was funny oh they can repeat it
like how we repeat history
Krysten Ritter Kristen she was the
girlfriend from Breaking Bad the one
that died oh so you just didn't turn her
over you didn't save her so have you
guys seen the show of the good place yes
okay
was miscast as a degenerate [ __ ]
[ __ ] person because she does not look
like one okay she's just sweet love
period she looks like the [ __ ] girl
next door sweetheart whatever so you
have to spend more time as a writer
walking back to explain their image yeah
so I thought they should have cast
Kristen [ __ ] reader which is why I
started her the other day oh you're like
yeah she's like she could be a [ __ ] or
whatever yeah so that's work that's what
the pasty in that show lost me that's
all like comedy like her comedic
whatever how she delivers the lines that
are given to her like she just nails it
I don't believe it I just don't believe
it when I'm watching the show yeah I'm
saying like if i zoom out I know what
you're talking about but I'm like oh no
no that's one thing that a lot of actors
hate we're like you're kind of like
pigeon hell bite just there look it's
not students yeah if you want to play
all these roles but then if half of the
storytelling is based off what you look
like already it's it's it's hard well
then how do those other people like it's
mainly guys I get to do this where they
can play way different like they have a
crazy range in their head
what about the [ __ ] greatest actress
on earth whole mouth she barrels [ __ ]
Street [ __ ] she can do anything
Mary Ann I'm never gonna play Ellie I've
never seen mal she's scared to play
house
I've never seen a play [ __ ] mermaid
elves are pretty hard man hard to crack
what about fairy she wouldn't a fairy
you kill a fairy she hasn't been a fairy
godmother than anything I'm pretty sure
she has no no she hasn't guys she ever
been an octopus yeah okay she's Ursula
voice shikai I was told by my actor
teacher that when this is years ago
she's like if you ever want to be a lead
gotta lose some weight cuz you're fat
you'll always be the fat guy next door
funny for you next Chris Farley Kevin do
Seth Rogen santur you're talking about
is about the if you have a movie word
the selling point for women is like a
hot dude then that's where you get
that's what that's what she's talking
about
yeah are you trying to be sexy lead man
yeah but I don't want to be like super
sexy I just want to be a nice look you
know then you could play all the IceCube
roles hmm every black man yell at me
what do you think no surprisingly calm I
think we could do a little more in the
next take a little more please okay guys
remember you're black okay that's how
they talk
Hollywood more give me more more more
and it's like nobody talks wire bit more
Marc yeah we've been a pop of kappa
knees fool
did you ever hear this of the seediest
diversity showcase yes I did it stand up
a diverse sorry yeah need a cup of times
that is and then you know you know they
went with they went with people like
Chavez Gambino who did it like the the
experimental humor and stuff like it was
not the black experience it was that's a
safe enough and we got a [ __ ]
everybody's happy
that's exactly what it was so
[Music]
[Music]